[Music]
hey guys it's Jenna here so a lot of you
have been requesting for inner and outer
thighs for a count if you want to work
on this section it's all about moving
your hips okay so this workout will
combine some of my favorite kickboxing
moves such as sidekicks and also these
stripes it's going to work on your
entire body your heart rate will be
pumping and you will be sweaty that will
be eight exercises each workout will be
for thirty seconds long with fifteen
seconds rest in between so we want to
constantly be moving those hips so get
your body warmed up and give me your
best effort right I want you to loosen
up those hips and move those hips okay
so the first workout is going to be a
really simple curtsy lunge then shoulder
width apart toes pointed forward and I
want you to place both arms just by your
waist and just twist and tap down okay
ready let's go twist and touch good if
you want to you can place both hands
right in front of you so really twist
those hips twist it and feel your hips
working good keep going so this is just
a really simple warm-up to get your hips
to open up to begin with all right keep
going twist and cross over cross over if
you want to you can gently tap your knee
onto the floor and bring it back up good
give me two more and just rest it up
shake it out next workout would be a
kickboxing move so it's going to be a
side kick all right let's start with a
left leg kick and just drop your left
arms down right side drop and kick okay
remember to pull your legs back so drop
kick good twist and really lift your leg
as high as you can twist and drop good
kick remember don't just let it fall
okay be in control nice strong kicks
kick and pull it back
very good giving strong kicks twist your
side through your hips opening up twist
high legs very nice
keep going cake good let me see the
strong kicks last one and rest it up the
workout it's great to be and in all in
and out white squad okay so start in as
you hop out it's all about twisting
opening up hop in hop up twist okay
let's go out in good twist open up good
white toast point it out work on your
inner thighs so this workout will really
work on inner thighs as you twist pace
your breathing beginners if you want to
you can take a step in step out and
twist okay
find your own pace keep going last one
and shake it out rest it up both work
out nice strike another kick boxing move
alright so step shutter width apart toes
pointed forward I want you to drive your
right knee forward okay and just pull it
good let's go so it's all about opening
up the hips move it and open it up okay
good
open it up open it up all right it's not
going up it's going forward forward and
imagine your holy someone dragging the
neck dragging their body and just
striking them right at the core there
you go keep going remember it's not
going up it's going forward forward and
strike pull it back pull it back rest it
on now let's get down onto the mat first
what got right plank crunch so get down
onto your mat okay get into a side plank
alright and I just want you to start
with a simple crunch twist and open up
okay find a balance twist open up twist
and open good find your balance
feel your outer thigh your right outer
thigh working okay L
tap open up top and open up good keep
going so let's work on one side for the
first set okay and we will focus on the
other side on set number two all right
rest a little bit
next in a thigh lift so lower leg on the
floor up a lick you can place it on the
floor and you can simply just lift the
lower leg okay
you should feel your inner thigh if you
want to challenge yourself place the
other leg on top and just lift it up
okay so support the upper body it's a
really small movement but you will
really feel your inner thighs and also
your outer thigh working good just
working on one leg to begin with keep
going
lift it pulse it higher drop it down
pulse it pulse up and down good very
nice keep going last one now
let's rest and you're gonna love the
next move
so lie back down on the floor okay just
relax the upper body if you want to you
can support your butt slightly and we
want to do white seizes so it's up cross
over up and put it back
it really works on your inner and also
your outer thigh
okay pull it back drive it back in open
in good cross like a scissor
good keep going cross and really bring
it white and put it back keep going
ten more seconds you can even do this
workout on your bed first thing in the
morning if you want to last few more and
we have one final workout and now just
rest it out come back up into a new
alright start from in your position all
I wanted to do is hop open up got that
back into an ill hop
and open up ready let's go one last Rika
hop open up
neo back down ha the opposite side very
good
hop opposite side nice drive your hips
good drive your size push it up
okay halfway there new and hop again
beginners you can just take a step up
and back down okay but always maintain
low good last few more give me one more
on the other side and rest it at that
was a first set down okay now what is
that
keep yourself hydrated take a one-minute
break and we want to repeat set number
two I want you to give me your best
effort
right you have about 15 seconds rest
left okay it's your second set you know
all the workouts so I wanted to really
push yourself and give me your best
after it okay if you want to you can
even speed up the work out slightly but
don't sacrifice proper form so let's
start with curtsy lunge
toes pointed forward shoulder width
apart and thumbs up let's go twist and
touch down very good hands by a weight
if you want to good keep going move
those hips okay
this workout it's all about moving those
hips good keep going look forward and
twist okay look forward and twist very
good touch and taps to really go low up
low and up good low up and low last one
more and just shake it off next move six
sidekicks okay so remember drop the amp
that you're kicking ready I'm up always
guarding your face ready three seconds
and let's go kick drop it down kick
that's high you can drop it down drive
your leg back okay don't just a default
kick find your balance
kick and feel your outer thighs and your
hips working very good give me strong
kicks okay point your side look to your
side drop your arm very nice just like a
cake box very nice guys
keep going woo drive it Hilux don't drop
now Hilux okay you just got a few more
left one last one and just shake it out
next in and out white squad with a twist
okay so remember to always point your
toes out and start white five more
seconds breathe huh and let's go twist
hop twist hop twist and open point your
toes out this is to work on your inner
thighs twist if you want to give a clap
let's go clap clap with me good come on
I want you so you really see your sweat
dripping and your heart rate pumping
keep going twist last few more one more
small post workout kickboxing move knee
strike again it's all about opening up
your hips and drive the knee forward
okay not to the top about forward Oh
panting away but we got this let's go
drive it forward forward open up those
hips
imagine you're pooling and dragging
someone close to you okay knee them
right at the car pulling pull it and
pull it back good lean back to drive the
knee forward okay you can even tiptoe
and really drive those knee forward good
lean your upper body back slightly very
good
three more seconds last two and good
breathe rest it out let's get down onto
the mat let's go so we worked on our
left now let's work on our right side
okay it's a lie down side play ready up
crunch
twist open and crunch okay find your
balance lift your hips up okay
don't let it for up twist and open up
good very nice strong arms strong upper
body strong core everything
keep it strong good keep twisting one
more and last one
and now just relax lightly in a thigh
lift choose your option okay lower leg
down up a link-up support your upper
body and we want to do small pulses all
right ready let's go small pulses if you
want to point your toes forward very
very small pulses feel your inner thigh
working sometimes it's all about working
on those really small muscles by doing
small movement okay no big movement
praise your breathing find your rhythm
don't drop your leg right now okay lift
it up and down good up and down up and
down nice white caesars all right
so lie back down okay um if you want to
just by your tips by your but leave your
legs up white cross good
let's go cross and pull it back in okay
cool
why and put it back in good control the
movement nice nice and control feel your
inner thighs and your outer thighs
fighting against the resistance of your
own body good keep going and you have
one last workout right after
this worked on I just rested up no
stopping one last workout new to the
opposite side okay so breathe in take a
deep breath
find one seconds rest okay stay with me
stay with me alright let's go new pop
open up twist new pump and open up twist
and hop good down top good your match
should be sweaty and you should be
pumping with endorphins keep going
remember your sweat is your fat crying
twist and move those hips last few more
one more on the other side last one more
okay twist yeah well done very very very
well done that was two sets all the
exercises will be targeting your inner
and also your outer thighs okay it's a
total body workout move to really get
your entire body working and to move
your hips if you want to challenge
yourself repeat this entire video again
and do a total of four sets for best
results remember to do this workout
three to four times weekly okay combine
it with my other upper body workouts and
also core exercises do like this video
give this video a thumb up share it and
subscribe to my youtube channel for all
of my work of videos fitness tips
recipes and also challenges you can also
get lots of workout and also meal plans
don't forget to turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new video
and it is every week all the best you've
done so well